التقدم الاوكراني بوصمه العرض تسمم عشرات
التلميذات بحادثين منفصلين في افغانستان
الامير هاري يستعد للمثول امام المحكمه
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم الى
[موسيقى]
هجوم جديد شنه قائد مجموعه فاجنر على
المسؤولين الروس بعد استعاده القوات
الاوكرانيه جزءا من بلده فيباخمت شرق
اوكرانيا وصفا ما حصل بانه وصمت عار على
القياده العسكريه الروسيه كان قائد القوات
البريه الاوكرانيه
اعلن ان قوات بلاده تواصل التقدم بالقرب
من بخموت بدوره قال حاكم بالقرود الروسيه
ان القوات الاوكرانيه واصلت القصف على
المنطقه الحدوديه بعشرات الصواريخ
والقذائف دون الاشاره الى وقوع ضحايا
بصوره مريبه تعيد الى اللهذان ما حصل في
ايران قبل فتره اصيبت عشرات الفتيات
الافغانيات بالتسمم وتم نقلهن الى
المستشفى بعده هجومين منفصلين على مدرستين
في ولايه شمال افغانستان واوضح محمد رحمن
رئيس اداره التعليم بالمقاطعه ان قرابه 80
طالبه تعرضنا للتسمم في منطقه
حيث اصيب 60 منهن في مدرسه نسوانكابود اب
وسبعه عشره طالب اخرى في مدرسه نسوان فايز
اباد
رحماني اكد ان تحقيقات لا تزال جاريه لكن
المعلومات الاوليه اظهرت ان شخص لديه
ضاغينه دفع لطرف ثالث لتنفيذ الهجمات وفقا
لحديثه
غاب الامير البريطاني هاري اليوم عن جلسه
بمقر المحكمه العليا في لندن تنظر في دعوى
رفعها ضد مؤسسه صحفيه بريطانيه ما دفع
القاضي للقول انه مندهش لغيابه اليوم ان
قال احد محاميل مؤسسه صحفيه ان غيابه غير
عادي ومن المتوقع ان يدلي الامير هاري
الابن الاصغر الملك تشارلز بشهادته على
منصه الشهود غدا الثلاثاء ليصبح اول فرد
رفيع المستوى في الاسره المالكه
البريطانيه يدلي بشهادتها امام محكمه منذ
130 عاما
التحذيرات من الذكاء الاصطناعي لا تزال
متواصله لكن هذه المره المخاوف تتعلق
بالارهاب فوفقا لصحيفه جاردن حذر خبراء من
مراقبه الارهاب من مخاطر تكنولوجيا
الجديده التي تسيطر على عقول البسطاء
الخبراء اوضح ان الذكاء الاصطناعي قادر
على تجنيد الشباب داخل غرف نومهم وشيرين
الى انه يجب على العالم ان يتوخى الحذر
والا يتهاون مع هذه المساله التي قد تحول
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الى منصه لتبادل
المحتوى الارهابي وسناده لذلك طالبت
الهيئه المراقبه في بريطانيا مبتكرين
الذكاء الاصطناعي بوضع ضوابط وقواعد
لاستخدام التقنيه